like Shelton has found his gal he was so
cute home lady Fair Oscar party
Blake is working on a new album and he
told me two songs are going to be very
personal and Spencer is so much his
whole life changed when his marriage
ended with Brad Lambert it doesn't take
a rocket scientist if you if you
followed my career even a little bit or
my life I mean you know what's happening
with me in the last you know Josh eight
or nine months and it's all on there
it's all on the record I mean you get to
a point where you just gotta I think you
just gotta you know let the past be the
past and move on I found Blake to be
sincere open even bringing up his
divorce and writing about it himself
when it comes to his music he always
seems to pour his soul into every word
do you feel like it's healing in a way
like a lot of people say that about
music I sure do I think you know that I
can put my life experiences whether it's
a divorce
or or my new girlfriend I have music I
can write songs I can sing about it
when's been singing about her man - and
he's sweet talking about halo the horse
win posted on instagram and hashtag
quote best present ever I gave her the
horse and bought myself
we bought I actually got her a horse and
I got my self a horse at the same time
because oh when she loves riding and she
loves horses and you can expect to see
more of their chemistry now that the
boys is back when Stefani's is my mentor
this season and you talk about an
absolute legend legendary musical icon
and somebody who's been a coach on that
show you know I go hey you wanna be my
mentor this season she's not sure okay
Gwyn said she'll did Lake and I got
together as he launched Smith works
vodka he's an ambassador for the brand
and considered part of the family
it's from where I'm from and so the fact
that they came to me and you know I got
a chance to taste it and they told me
that they wanted me to be you know a
part a part of the making of it you know
it's like you know that's I like vodka